ladies and Gentlemen please welcome  Whitney Houston  [Applause]  a common criticism of you your music  isn't black enough who said that that's  just Bull and it makes me angry actually  it's hateful and uninformed a whole life  saying black man she ain't white enough  well how about she's not obedient enough  how about she ain't fearful enough  [Music]  music is not a color to me it has no  boundaries I think what I want to sing  be how I want to be  and who's as big an audience as I can  no one is like you you can sing with me  your daddy's princess  we're building something here so you  just keep singing Daddy  my money  trusted you do you want me to look out  for me  [Music]  YouTube has spent a lot of time together  it's damaging the brand since winter  little girl become the brand I miss that  don't even worry about it you're Whitney  Houston  [Music]  [Applause]  love  millions of people  foreign  I ever know  [Music]